i i uh sorry to go back to the gym
mm-hmm to bring it up again um i was in
the gym and uh i was watching an anime
to go along with gym experience is this
the only time you watch anime man you've
been talking about watching anime a lot
recently no twice twice
that
of course and i watched it and like my
god if you haven't started watching
becky like you need to get i haven't
seen this new season yet is it like it's
this is probably the greatest season of
television i've ever seen
this [ __ ] was so goddamn funny yeah i i
cause cause part three bucky which is
the new season is my favorite in pokemon
honestly i've i was like trying to work
out but i just couldn't stop laughing
like
just some of the plot points it honestly
puts jojo to shame at the time yeah yeah
stupid the show part three is when it
really starts to get [ __ ] you don't
know what becky is i don't even know how
to explain it it's just men with muscles
fighting and it's just so [ __ ]
basically a kid who's like i want to be
the strongest creature on the planet and
then he does everything he can to be the
strongest there's there's no way we can
describe in words what back he is kind
of like it's kind of like jojo you kind
of just have to experience the reason
why it doesn't do as as as well as joe
jokes i think it doesn't have like an
aesthetic that is quite as appealing as
yeah yeah jojo has so much john just so
much style and stuff to go around with
it yeah uh but but i think becky is
almost more [ __ ] stupid you know
is one of those like illustrators where
i'm like are you really good at drawing
or are you really shy so like like i
don't know
there are some scenes where i'm like
damn that's an amazing shot and then
other scenes i'm like i don't think this
man has ever seen a human being in his
life
because that is not how anatomy works
it's it's like you take a character and
you're like let's make this a muscly
character and you're like what what
proportions do you think is reasonable
reasonable for a muscly character and
then the author just went all right
multiply that by ten and then that's the
that's like the every character every
single character even the weak
characters are like built like bricks
yeah right it's insane and like i could
tell you some plot points and i will and
they won't even spoil it for you because
it won't make any [ __ ] sense right so
at one point during the show the main
protagonist becky uh starts shadow
boxing right that's my favorite [ __ ]
scene is it the mantis so yeah that as
well but so he starts
this is it's like a 10 year old kid and
he's like look i'm going to show you
that i'm going to fight an opponent and
so he starts fighting the air and then
he starts fighting um mike tyson yeah oh
this one this one mike tyson appears out
of thin air and mike tyson isn't there
but mike tyson is landing blows and he's
physically [ __ ] he physically gets hurt
and then he's fighting him back and then
the kid can see the spirit of mike tyson
and then this just happens
and then he's like and then the main
character is like oh yeah mike tyson's
weak and then he just summons a praying
mantis that beats the [ __ ] out of it but
then he starts fighting the praying
mantis that's imaginary yeah yeah in in
a room right like
like some military guys like hey come
fight and then he's like no and then he
just kidnaps george bush and it's like
what's going on what is what is going on
what is going on he's talking about
biscuit oliver right yeah then he
kidnaps in this plot he kidnaps george
bush yeah so he can go to prison yeah
yeah yeah but like so then he can beat
up all the prisoners why would george
bush help you go to prison if if if you
kidnap him they would just what does it
make any sense i love how bucky just
like is so with the times like you know
exactly when part three was so
watching becky right is like
if you only learned about america
through trash taste yeah yeah it's
literally
the [ __ ] they they say about it there's
this one [ __ ] uh they i i had to
pause it cause i just [ __ ] laughed my
ass off
and uh this is one point where this
american prison guard is about to die
and uh the two japanese guys one of them
saves the japanese guy saves the
american and the other japanese goes why
would you save an american he's never
gonna care about you he's american
i just paused it and it was like
what
what does that mean what is this just
like casual like what
in my country why would you save an
american they wouldn't care about you
yes
holy
i'll never [ __ ] figure and i can't
wait for them to adapt this i think it's
part four uh and it's when uh
barack obama comes out yeah yeah because
he gets so in the manga he's like newly
elected right so he's like you know the
era of when this was written and uh like
hama yujirah like the main like the dad
guy who's like the most powerful guy
he's like he goes to talk to obama
because of course he can yeah
like the main antagonist could just sit
down with anyone yeah just because he's
so busy because he's so built it's just
like it's safe but like but like obama
at first is like i've heard of that man
i don't trust him
[Music]
i don't trust him at all but like i need
to see is he the real deal i need to see
if he's the real deal so then he comes
into the room and he's like show me
you're the real deal and
and use your and eugero goes all right
bet and he grabs like a handful of sand
and he crushes it in his hand and turns
it into a diamond moment
i didn't even i didn't even know what
he's gonna do
and then obama's like you are the real
one
shakes hands
so there's like this show big muscle if
you if you if you haven't watched mackie
you like you're honestly doing yourself
at this point it's so fun
because like get past the start it can
be a little jank but like the anime is
really good it's really funny because
like i'm surprised that meme culture
just hasn't picked up on bucky memes
right because so much of this is [ __ ]
meme i know right like that's one of the
things
it's so [ __ ] funny so apparently
right because these there's these three
characters becky uh the the uh yuji
rohan yeah and and oliver biscuit the
other guy yeah this is three guys that
are so dangerous and so powerful because
they're muscles right yeah that half of
the the gps in the world is is on it's
in the air
solely to track down
and so whenever they run above two
kilometers an hour the gps has to all
the gps in the world has to stop working
yeah just to track these tracks
so and there's a whole section where
they explain that when people are
driving or using their phone the gps
just doesn't work correctly because some
of these characters decided to go for a
light jog
you can't make this [ __ ] up who thought
of this [ __ ]
i'm telling you man
like that's the thing if people if you
thought jojo was ridiculous yeah judge's
witches it could be as ridiculous as
pakistan and you combine that with then
also another part in another season
where yuja rohanna again the main
antagonist meets muhammad ali and he and
he's he's like you could you can't beat
me because you took off to do important
human rights things yeah but i respect
you because you did that and it's like
what is going on is it one of the
antagonists like muhammad ali's son
yeah but even though he's weaker than
him because he went to he he took time
about his career yeah to to argue for
civil rights yeah great we love it but
then
junior is just like cocky yeah and then
he gets like
but then he like but then he like
kidnaps like the main like love
interesting and then gets beaten up by
like five dudes for five days straight
just like over and over and over there
was also obviously i love where it's
like hanayama koda who's like my
favorite [ __ ] character he's like
he he's like bored so he's just like oh
man everyone's weak everyone's [ __ ]
wait no one can stand up to me except
one man humble you you know what i'm
gonna go pay him a visit so he goes and
pays him a visit he's just like walking
down the street and he's like so we're
gonna start fighting and he's like right
here like yeah
just in the middle of a crowd but then a
kid comes up and it's like oh my god
eudro i'm a massive fan of you and like
hands him like a shkishi right it's like
can you sign this sketchy
[Music]
and you know normally you think he pulls
out a pen does the same no this is a
hammer he's built different yeah what he
does is he stabs he gets his finger he
stabs the shikishi and then slices it
into four quarters with his finger until
it's like all broken apart and the kid's
like
oh my god thank you so much and hanayama
card is like man i'd be happier with
that than a signature for me
and i was like what is this and then
they start beating the [ __ ] out of each
other it's just like it is insane like i
i'm i'm sure if you don't know anything
about becky that probably sound makes no
sense and it doesn't make it doesn't
make any sense don't mean context
yeah i just i i still don't quite
understand what the story is and i've
watched three seasons yeah i don't get
the point of course i'm like you watch
the netflix season yeah and the netflix
seasons aren't even the beginning of the
story because the netflix seasons are
like starting season two yeah it's like
a sequel to an anime or like the manga
that came out like decades ago and then
it's been going longer yeah yeah yeah
has gotten a lot better as well in the
season the cgi is kind of jank in the
first season i think but still watch it
it is really fun i mean i would say like
the animation especially compared to
jojo isn't as good but
like you don't watch it for the
animation you watch it from like the bat
[ __ ] crazy scenes it's just like it's
just insane how they decide fights and
it's like imagine if a world was decided
purely by muscle
like
the whole it's like muscles can solve
every world issue in the in the world
guns in this world are meaningless
compared to muscles like
guns don't do anything guns are a
suggestion
guns are for normal human beings and
they don't operate in the same world
that the characters do like it's it's
like every single character is an
avengers level threat that's just that's
just what it is right and
every single time you think you've met
the strongest character no they he they
introduce some new character that is
even stronger who's the main one in uh
the part three again is it the the
prehistoric guy is it the first human uh
no no no so so i believe they've done
what they did with the first uh season
well it's certainly one season split
into two oh i think that's what they've
done here so the first arc is just
through the prison yeah yeah and then
the next arc is the prehistoric yeah the
pickle right but this this arc opens up
with um
a press conference from like a safari
where
like all these people died to this giant
mammoth elephant which killed hundreds
of people and
and uh animals yeah
and in this press conference he's like
one man killed this this 500
meter tall man well that's what i know
like and then like the press conference
is like no no no it didn't and then it's
like what is this what is this
it's so dumb
[Music]
that's what i love about bucky is that
every character has such as this batshit
crazy backstory yeah the way they get
introduced with this like [ __ ] crazy
backstory and you have like speed wagon
like
basically a narrator just going over
their entire backs doing all these like
batshit crazy things and you think it
can't get crazier until it [ __ ] does
every time i've like almost caught up to
the manga and i'm like how how did they
top the first human ever who ever lived
who beat a [ __ ] tyrannosaurus rex
with his bare hands
even though i know sort of what the next
jokes are about yeah this is an arc
about them fighting prehistoric
creatures right yeah yeah we're just
like what the [ __ ] they just bring them
back to life and they're like let's see
if they stand up to the humans today
like like like jurassic park instead if
they turned in to test the humans
instead of like test seeing what the
dinosaurs could do it's like let's see
what the humans can do against the
dinosaurs because humans are humans are
too boring in this world yeah apparently
because it's just like every you know
no normal martial arts master is good
enough anymore now yeah but it's just so
funny because like the main protagonist
which is the main character's dad is
just like that [ __ ] insane and also just
hilarious yeah it's just like he's so
insane some of the [ __ ] he says it's
actually insane
the fact there's a whole whole scene
dedicated to him watching his son having
sex and that was that was what sold me
on the first honestly if
if i can't sell you on becky is that
that there is a scene where he is about
to lose his virginity yeah and his dad
comes in giving him advice yeah in like
the creepiest way uh
please watch this show it is insane the
fact that people haven't watched this is
just mind-blowing he literally squats
down next to the bed and says
eat her yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] every day drunk every day
answer your instincts let your instincts
take over become an animal [ __ ] what you
want
to top it off bucky turns [ __ ] super
saiyan levels
after he loses his virginity
if they have they have like a [ __ ]
because like they actually have sex
and they turn the sex scene into a jojo
fight i swear to god yeah you're just
like oh sex sex is like a battle
i'm gonna be honest though it is in real
life you're like trying to think of like
ten things at once make sure you do it
right start with accurate sex in the
anime change my mind no on top of that
right not only is this the hyper sex
scene in anime immediately after that
you don't need this no [ __ ] goku
super saiyan i'm going to save the world
this man powered up more than goku ever
wishes he could by losing his virginity
they these people can sense that this
man lost his virginity they did he was
he was fighting oh yeah that's right
because one of the prison guys like
tries to come on no no not one two
before this
main character was so weak that he
couldn't face one of these dudes
one-on-one yeah after sex two of them
come in and they cannot face him like
this man's aura this man's nan has
increased so much from busting a nut
that like they can't even think of
facing he somehow developed like hockey
power obviously
it's it's like gone
versus postman
it's like if god turned into his dad
after nothing it's insane like it's this
whole episode was like you had to pause
it and just be like what the [ __ ] is
going on
please watch wacky it is insane it's
amazing i i cannot and this new season
was so goddamn fun i was gonna only
watch like two episodes i've binged it
all in one day oh it's so fun it's it's
insane like i have to watch it if you go
into it with the mindset of this is
going to be a kind of stupid jojo esque
show i guarantee you will love it yeah
if you can watch it with the boys the
[ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious
we need our bucky out of context kind of
compilation just like get this going
just how do we know zero memes of
barking yeah yeah yeah it's like there
are like so many out of context jojo
memes and compilations but there's
nothing for bucky no like how i don't
it's it deserves crimes
like
it's just i could think of so many
there's so many scenes so many clips of
this goddamn show that deserve to be me
oh my god oh my lord no but i'm going
back for my life for vacuum my god